[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est
d'ailleurs de par le manque d'eau on est
là pour 30 minutes pour faire le tour de
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
bien évidemment au jour catllar bonjour
michael et nous accueillons aujourd'hui
eric coquerel aujourd'hui primo au
député député france insoumise de
seine-saint-denis on va revenir avec
vous sur les moments forts de cette
semaine
la déclaration de politique générale les
parlementaires ont accordé la confiance
à edouard philippe mais les français ne
sont pas tout à fait convaincu selon un
sondage à l'assemblée le coup d'envoi de
la réforme du code du travail la
ministre a expliqué ses intentions
examen express en commission et puis
nous sommes toujours sous état d'urgence
après le sénat l'assemblée a adopté le
projet de loi qui le prolonge en
attendant une loi de sécurité intérieure
lequel oui on commence par ce début de
semaine marquée par le vote de confiance
à l'assemblée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors edouard philippe dans un long
discours a mis le cap sur les réformes
et tracer la feuille de route pour le
quinquennat feu vert donc des
parlementaires mais aussi certains
évidemment ont voté contre et se sont
abstenus regardez là emmanuel macron le
cap à edouard philippe la méthode devant
un hémicycle animé d'abord applaudi le
premier ministre se fait chaque départ
ses détracteurs au moment des questions
relatives au budget à la fiscalité
ces cinq fois le budget de la justice
le premier ministre a la parole dès le
début de son discours edouard philippe
multiplie les références puis il rend
hommage au premier ministre qui l'ont
précédé avant de dresser rapidement le
portrait des nouveaux députés
je vois une assemblée rajeuni et
féminisé et largement renouvelée après
plus d'une heure de discours se
succèdent au perchoir les présidents de
groupe premier à prendre la parole
richard ferrand devant des bancs du
parti socialiste qui se vide
mes chers collègues celles et ceux qui
quittent l'hémicycle sont invités à le
faire en toute discrétion pour laisser
l'orateur s'exprimer dans les meilleures
conditions
place ensuite au président du premier
groupe d'opposition à l'assemblée
christian jacob réaffirme son souhait
d'incarner une opposition libre et
exigeante
j'espère mais je ne me fais pas beaucoup
d'illusions quand vous regardant dans la
glace
il vous arrive de songer à vos anciens
collègues dont votre nomination à
contribuer à la perte de son côté le
président du groupe nouvelle gauche
olivier faure qui rassemble les
socialistes demandent au premier
ministre de redéfinir sa marque
la république en marche se veut un bébé
qu str elle assure tout pour l'instant
était ambiguë puis c'est au tour de jean
luc mélenchon le chef du groupe de la
france un solide dénonce lui un coup
d'état social nous ne voulons pas être
seulement votre position nous nous
présentons comme l'alternative au monde
que vous représentez l'assemblée
nationale vote finalement la confiance
au gouvernement avec 370 voix pour 67
contre 129 députés se sont abstenus
mystère vous vous êtes abstenu vous avez
voté contre pardon ce vote de confiance
il ya une large abstention ce qu'on a
parlé pendant le reportage eux il ya eu
tout un tas de promesses qui avaient été
formulées pendant la campagne électorale
qui on voit aujourd'hui notamment sur
des baisses d'impôts finalement qui
seront peut-être retarder ou enterrés
selon vous bah en fait d'une part de
l'ensemble des députés france a soumis à
voter contre si ça parce qu'il ya eu
quelques votes contre ailleurs dans
l'assemblée mais c'est ce qui nous fait
dire qu'on est le groupe d'opposition
unis et dans l'opposition voilà alors
sur les baisses d'impôts je ne sais pas
si elles viendront mais vous en faites
l'épisode de cette semaine commence par
l'audit de la cour des comptes
enfin la semaine dernière et semaine
dernière voilà c'est ce qui prépare le
discours du premier ministre avec 3par
et du congrès de versailles d'autres
avec une vision catastrophiste de dudu
du budget pour koné ça pour nous
préparer à nous dire bailleur falloir
encore serrer la ceinture
et puis effectivement certaines
dispositions vont être retardées alors
notamment par exemple si j'ai bien
compris sur la taxe d'habitation je ne
porte pas un jugement positif sur la
disparition de la taxe d'habitation ou
en tout cas telle qu'elle est prévue
mais on voit bien que cela est remporté
par contre ce qui n'est pas reportée
c'est la question de la csg alors que
pendant la campagne nous a expliqué que
l'une l'une quelque part permettait
l'autre c'est à dire qu'il ya des taxes
d'habitation qui disparaissait mais par
la csg comment dire été augmenté
notamment pour les barouds baba se
traîne mais par contre il y avait la
taxe d'aller se battre surtout au point
en réalité là du coup ça fait perdre en
perdant c'est à dire qu'il veut une
augmentation de la csg
par exemple pour un retraité gagne 1200
euros s'est maintenue ça lui coûtait
environ 250 euros est par contre la taxe
d'habitation non donc oui on va se
battre et on va se battre sur ces
petites d'austérité qui sont en train de
revenir a grandi c'est ce qu'on en parle
justement il ya eu cette annonce de
gérard d'al banna qui veut rétablir qui
a décidé d'établir le jour de carence
des fonctionnaires c'est-à-dire qu'ils
sont pas payés le premier jour de leur
arrêt maladie qu'est ce que vous pensez
de cette mesure est ce que c'est une
stigmatisation et bien sûr et je vais
vous annoncer la suite ils vont remettre
de façon ferme
la suppression d'un fonctionnaire
partant à la retraite sur deux ils vont
re continuer à geler le point d'indicé
des fonctionnaires je vous rappelle
qu'il est gelé depuis 2010 ce qui fait
que par rapport à l'augmentation du du
de la vie ces sept points de perdu et
c'est une façon de toujours fustigé les
mêmes alors même que pour notre part ou
le savez nous estimons que s'il y a une
dilapidation de la richesse nationale
c'est plutôt du côté des des dividendes
du fonctionnaire finale estimant qu'ils
aient faire les gouvernants les
fonctionnaires sont les boucs émissaires
et c'est toujours le même procédé vous
dire l'état coûte trop cher les services
publics ou lynch à la fonction publique
ou trop chères nous nous opposons
fermement à cette idée qui non seulement
affaiblit l'état affaibli la solidarité
nationale mais je vous rappelle aussi
que les dépenses publiques ce sont aussi
des recettes dans le pays mais exclut ce
sont des gens qui consomment qui qui qui
donc une un rôle actif dans l'économie
donc c'est quelque chose qui est
problématique et vous êtes membre de la
commission des finances à l'assemblée
donc vous aller batailler sur tous ces
points
ces ag oui on va batailler et d'ailleurs
avec encore une fois monsieur migaud qui
est venu devant la commission on a donc
sonné à l'avance quasiment le programme
du gouvernement c'est à dire qu'on voit
bien que c'est plus trop où j'allais
dire
l'audit commandé qui conduit à la
politique gouvernement ce qui est quand
même un petit peu exagéré de la part de
la commission
l'accès de commissions qui te répondra
pas drôle évidemment de d'exister par
rapport aux promesses qui ont été faites
pendant l'élection et même juste après
vous dites aujourd'hui quoique des
promesses qui ne seront pas tenues
spassky diallo dit qui est tombée et que
du coup c'est plus la même politique et
il ya une partie des promesses qui vont
être tenues je peux vous dire qu'ils
vont effectivement supprimés sont à
mille fonctionnaires
je peux vous dire qu'ils vont
effectivement faire des mesures
drastiques encore mais par contre les
quelques mesures
j'allais dire qu'il permettait d'alléger
l'impôt je n'y crois pas je ne crois pas
qu'elles vont venir qu'ils ont tout
simplement parce que ils ont toujours
cette règle imbécile excusez moi le
terme des 3 % c'est que ça a été décidée
à jour griffonné dans les années 80 ils
ont eu plus de trois et demi deux
ennemis c3 qui nous qui nous conduit à
faire des politiques inverse à la gérer
l'intérêt de notre pays aille en images
cette semaine notre qui a fait le tour
un peu des télévisions bien évidemment
ce sont vous les parlementaires de la
france a soumises place de la bastille
ya aussi les élus communistes qui est un
peu plus tôt devant les grilles du
château de versailles remparts l'est
pour le congrès
ces deux rassemblements pour un seul et
même combat
oui oui c'est à dire que là c'était un
rassemblement cette fois ci pour dire
nous n'étions pas d'accord avec la façon
très hyperprésidentialiste on peut dire
puisque c'est à versailles on peut
parler un peu de monarchie
présidentielle quoi oui il fait pas ça
par hasard le maire de mâcon dans lequel
est en train de s'installer
c'est ce qu'a kenna c'est quelque chose
qui ne va pas nous avons eu en plus
raison parce que pendant au moment où
les parlementaires étaient en train de
s'assoupir à versailles en écoutant un
discours très franchement assez
lénifiant
j'ai trouvé celui du premier plus en
plus dynamique personnellement eh bien
nous nous avons trahi d amendement sur
la loi travail ce qui fait que nous
avons déposé deux tiers des amendements
sur cette loi qui va passer à partir de
lundi à l'assemblée
alors justement la réforme du code du
travail va passer comme vous le dites à
l'épreuve de l'assemblée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors il y a eu cette semaine une
audition de la ministre du travail
devant la commission des affaires
sociales puis un examen devant cette
même commission examen expresse que nous
résume céline martel merci à vous le
projet de loi est donc adopté c'est un
passage express en commission des
affaires sociales pour le projet
d'habilitation visant à réformer le
droit du travail par ordonnance en moins
de 24 heures
les neuf articles du texte ont été
adoptés tel que rédigé par le
gouvernement aucun amendement n'a été
votée un examen au pas de course
vivement dénoncée par le groupe nouvelle
gauche les communistes et la france est
soumise
nous sommes convoqués ici en séance
extraordinaire beaucoup d'entre nous ne
dispose pas encore de leur bureau ni
même des collaborateurs qu'ils doivent
encore recruter ne comprenons pas bien
les raisons de cet empressement
sinon qu'il s'agisse d'empêcher
d'entraver la prise de conscience dans
le pays sur l'ampleur de ce que vous
apprêtez à faire très présente aux
commissions la ministre du travail mme
muriel pénicaud rappelle la philosophie
de sa réforme
on fait confiance ou pas ou dialogue
social tout le pari de la loi des
projets de lois d'habitation et des
ordonnances et de faire pareil le pari
que le dialogue social apporte une
valeur économique et social aux
entreprises aux salariés et aux pays les
opposants de gauche ne voteront pas le
projet de loi d'habilitation
contrairement aux constructif et aux
républicains ce n'est pas un blanc-seing
nous serons très vigilants
en fait sur le contenu des ordonnances
et en particulier nous avons deux points
de vigilance
la négociation dans les petites
entreprises et le deuxième sujet sur la
pénibilité
les séances auront été marqués par le
silence des députés de la république en
marche
parmi eux seul aurélien tâche et a
défendu un amendement je pense que si
nous continuons à travailler de cette
manière ça augure de la qualité des
travaux de notre commission le texte
sera examiné lundi prochain dans
l'hémicycle je vous donne rendez-vous
lundi
voilà examen très rapide on a presque
rarement vu ça en commission qu'est-ce
que vous à vous inspirent ces la réforme
de la procédure parlementaire avant
l'heure j'ai trouvé que le prémice le
jour faisait de l'humour noir c'est
entendu il a expliqué que
on est j'y ferai pas dans la
précipitation
on voit bien que c'est tout à fait là
merci c'est à dire qu'il faut faire
passer en plein été un coup de force
jean luc mélenchon appelle un coup
d'état social puisque ça inverse quand
même le la logique du code du travail
qui est une construction acquise après
100 ans de luttes sociales dans ce pays
et ils la font passer non seulement en
catimini ou de gens sont partis en
vacances ce qui est pour eux est
soi-disant le et la garantie pense-t-il
de deux mois de mobilisation mais en
plus avec effectivement des débats des
débats houleux parlement régner dans son
os et à l'émission de danse très bien
c'est à dire excusez moi mais l'usure
des initiés
banier c'est à dire que partiellement
vous fait passer des ordonnances qui ce
qu'on votait avance julien concours
autour du 20 juillet je me rappelle plus
la date exacte et qui repartent vous
savez qu'après les ordonnances peuvent
être sont complétés c'est à dire une et
sans travail parlementaire donc yade il
ya quelque chose qui est du de lors
d'une des mesures expéditives dans
lesquelles le parlement ne peut pas
l'enlever quand même c'est le
législateur regarde toujours un pouvoir
pour après revoilà ce qu'est ce que vous
pouvez
ces pouvoirs c'est cette avenue c'est à
dire quand une fois que les en deux ans
soir sont actives elles peuvent être
appliqués vous le savoir elle râle
devienne loi galland il ya effectivement
la loi d'habilitation qui veut t hawk
ivre dans les six mois
oui et s'avancer dans les détails de la
procédure ça veut dire que vous avez
quand même des démarches de l'année
comme on n'a pas les mêmes marges que de
discuter pied à pied des amendements
d'une loi connue détaillé il a c'est une
ouate courte qui nous est présentée qui
va être remplie ensuite par le
gouvernement dont vous voyez bien que il
ya un problème majeur
alors on nous dit c'est au nom de la
concertation sociale mais même les
syndicats j'ai entendu prothèse en tout
cas la cgt l'a fait ces jours-ci sur le
fait que aussi se retrouve dans une
situation où ils se retrouvent devant un
à ce que l'aide de textes et sans réelle
possibilité d'influer tués
de toute façon nous ayons pas hypocrite
on en connaît la logique
la logique c'est la version des normes
c'est à dire que l'accord d'entreprise
devient supérieure à la loi c'est le
fait de sécuriser les licenciements avec
la barémisation d'aider des indemnités
prud'homale il s'est par exemple ce cdi
de chantier qui en réalité la fin du
sinistre
l'examiner lundi je voudrais revenir un
petit peu sur le son le travail en
commissions parce qu'on a vu que sur les
images et même dans le reportage que
finalement tout va très vite
les députés de la république en marche
n'a pas beaucoup entendue également
c'est quelque chose que vous dénoncez
ils n'ont pas le droit au chapitre c'est
quoi c'est une voiture ayant perdu leurs
moyens termes comme l'instant je leur
fait pas toujours ce qu'il ya quelques
uns d'entre eux qui commencent un petit
peu à nous dire des choses en oeuvre
donc on va bien voir comment ça vous
savez dites le nous alors mais non mais
je je je les connais pas suffisamment
mon nom nadir marque donc nous notre
objectif vous le dis très franchement ça
va être d'essayer d'en convaincre une
certaine partie de modifier les règles
parce que nous savons que certains ont
été investis et sont pas forcément tous
alignés derrière la pensée d'un mode
macro mais pour l'instant je dois
constater que dans les débats
on va dire que c'est une majorité
godillot voilà qui applaudit quand on
lui demande les questions les jours à
l'assemblée vous utilisez regarder à
mary une exception près du côté la
polynésie s'il n'ya compris de la
représentant la polynésie je manque je
crois les autres c'était des questions
cireurs de pompes quoi enfin franchement
en quoi c'était une manière de dire au
gouvernement de donner l'occasion au
gouvernement de de vanter son son son
bilan bon voilà mais on s'y attendait un
peu on espèce de la durée ah bah
j'espère que l'on a duré seulement que
non j'espère que la vie parce que vous
avez retiré de mettre des coups un
certain moment nous savons qu'il y voilà
bon on verra bien en tout cas nous on va
juste rôle là on va jouer ce rôle à la
fois de d'opposante à dire pour essayer
notamment je vous dis très clairement de
ralentir tant que faire se peut dans les
visites dans l'hémicycle mais on va
essayer aussi de ralentir donc sans
obstructions barbade
on va se battre pied à pied c'est pas
une obstruction sur vouloir aux
parlementaires on n'est pas d'accord
doit se battre pied à pied comme on le
fait traditionnellement sur des
arguments
vous verrez à partir de lundi on à vic
toews un moment et pas que le président
de l'assemblée va g6 sûrement beewi
surtout qu'il a un côté politique aux
rigides et radiologie écoutez moi je les
ai vus hier pour un vote je pas si vous
avez vu mais il a il a ouvert un vote
est il dans la seconde même il l'a fermé
ce qui fait que il ya plein de gens y
compris contre comme nous étions qui
n'ont pas pu vous sur l'état d'urgence
voilà
tonnes de françois dumas pour l'instant
je le trouve voilà il faut peut-être
qu'ils mettent un peu de souplesse quoi
il ya peu d'adaptations l'autre jour je
sais bien que c'est les règles de
l'assemblée moi j'ai posé une question
il m'a coupé le sifflet à 0 bon je sais
que je sais que monsieur bartolone et
ses quelques secondes pour essayer de
finir la tolérance voilà je pense que
j'en appelle à il va peut-être évolué il
apprend aussi d'accord on va passer
maintenant
ce qui se passe au sénat sur la loi de
moralisation elle a été adoptée en
commission cette semaine et sera
exactement examiné la semaine prochaine
dans l'hémicycle samia des chemins nous
explique ce projet de loi le sénat pose
ses garde-fous aux projets de loi pour
la confiance dans l'action publique
le texte du gouvernement prévoit la
suppression de la réserve parlementaire
la commission des lois propose de la
remplacer par une dotation de soutien
exclusivement réservé aux communes
elle pourrait prétendre à une aide de 20
mille euros maximum
les projets seraient sélectionnés sur la
base de ces critères d'éligibilité parmi
une liste rendue publique
depuis trois ans les dotations des
communes des départements et des régions
ont baissé
tenez vous bien de 9,4 milliards d'euros
la réserve parlementaire ces 147
millions et si cette possibilité de
soutiens financiers n'est pas créée
alors ce sera au préjudice de communes
rurales et de leurs groupements qui
souffre déjà terriblement de
l'assèchement des financements publics
parmi les autres dispositions du texte
le sénat ne revient pas sur
l'interdiction des emplois familiaux
mais propose d'aider au départ des
collaborateurs concernés
en allongeant le délai de licenciement à
cinq mois contre deux dans le projet
gouvernemental et en créant un
dispositif personnalisé de retour à
l'emploi des collaborateurs licenciés
concernant la transparence des
indemnités de frais de mandat des
parlementaires
les sénateurs accepte le principe des
justificatifs pour leurs dépenses
mais la commission des lois estime qu'il
est difficile pour les sénateurs
d'avancé tous leurs frais avant d'être
remboursé elle propose donc de laisser
au bureau de chaque assemblée la
possibilité de définir les règles
cela permettrait de pouvoir bénéficier
d'avancés
or certains frais ça mais déjà nous a
donné le peu nous content du tout ce
qu'il ya dans ce texte peut-être
sûrement assez technique peut-être pour
pour la plupart des gens simplement est
ce que c'est un texte consensuel ou sur
lequel vous êtes prêts à voter
bah ça dépend ce qu'il ya dedans mais
enfin là on en sait un peu plus et oui
enfin pour moi vous savez nous on pense
que ça va pas assez loin c'est à dire
que si on veut vraiment réformer la vie
politique française
d'abord il faudra pas seulement
s'occuper du politique parce qu'il ya
une moralisation de la vie publique qui
concerne aussi possiblement d'autres
gens parlent nous sommes pour une
taxation différenciée le niveau des
impôts qu'ils fassent quand on se
garantit ce que font les américains ce
qu'on se garantissent que la wii et des
gens ne ne partent pas à l'étranger pour
faire l'évasion fiscale parce que vous
dites oh c'est d'aller plus loin
éventuellement jusqu'à faire une loi de
moralisation syndicale parce qu'on
enverra s'agit justement évoqué il doit
pas seulement syndicale
yahia il ya besoin d'une bille une loi
de moralisation public et je reviens
nous nous sommes pour intégrer pour
l'assomption bayrou nous avait expliqué
qu'il n'était pas d'accord avec ça là
qui sont la révocabilité des élus qui
nous paraît être le meilleur manière
d'avoir un contrôle sur un élu par qui
fait exactement l'inversé ce pourquoi il
a été mis en en françois hollande ou qui
justement au terme en termes de
d'affaires ou de manifeste qui n'est pas
verte le premier vide donc voilà nous
sommes pour instituer ce genre de et la
cepal vers ça qu'on se dirige on se
dirige vers des démesures est quelque
part qui pour certaines nouveau bien là
le normal qu'on vérifie avec des
factures par exemple seul et la tranchée
par les moteurs jusqu'à vous ne votez
pas forcément ce texte quand il arrivera
là non non bien sûr voir on va attendre
de voir ce qu'il ya dedans
alors cette semaine aussi eric coquerel
les députés ont prolongé l'état
d'urgence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
137 voix pour 13 contre dont la vôtre
celle de votre groupe france insoumise
eric coquerel
c'est la sixième prolongation de l'état
d'urgence jusqu'au 1er novembre le temps
de voter une nouvelle loi anti
terroriste écoutez ce qu'a dit le
ministre de l'intérieur un certain
nombre d'attentats d'attentats
extrêmement graves ont été déjoués
parce qu'à un moment donné nous n'avions
nous avions une information qui n'aurait
rien donné
devant le juge judiciaire ou alors il
aurait fallu des temps infini et si nous
n'avions pas eu ces perquisitions
administrative des attentats extrêmement
grave aurait pu se passer sur notre
territoire
et moi je ne serai pas le ministre qui
se contentera de faire des hommages
devant les cercueils de nos policiers ou
de nos concitoyens alors eric coquerel
vous est très présent pendant le débat
vous avez pris plusieurs fois la parole
pour dénoncer un peu les conditions dans
lesquelles ce fait cet examen est
expliqué nous qu'est ce qui vous pose
problème ce n'est pas le meilleur moment
de gérard collomb il a plein d'autres
qui l'a eu des explications avec plus de
discernement gêne pas cet extrait parce
que de ramener finalement ce qui
explique que la prolongation de l'état
d'urgence
affaibli l'état de droit et ne sert ne
n'est pas efficace dans la lutte contre
le terrorisme sur le long terme en leur
expliquant que finalement ils ne se
soucient pas de la mort des policiers
c'est pas bien leur position malien nous
sommes tous opposés au terrorisme et
nous sommes tous pour donner les moyens
de les abattre mais ce que nous disons
c'est que beaucoup aujourd'hui
observateurs estiment que le juge
trévidic par exemple mais également
emmanuel macron qui avait eu des phrases
fortes quand il était candidat que
l'état d'urgence affaibli l'état de
droit donc c'est rendre service quelque
part à ceux qui justement veulent miner
la république je parle je pense à dash
mais en l'occurrence ne donne pas des
moyens efficaces contre le terrorisme
qui serait plutôt le fait de renforcer
les services de renseignement avec
toujours plus de le besoin une matériel
et loire
et voilà c'est le fait c'est le fait de
vie d'amende- d'aller sur le foyer même
de terroristes à dire c'est un lien avec
la politique internationale de la france
mais bref c'est pas c'est pas
d'affaiblir est adroit ce que dit gérard
collomb c'est pas vrai il ya aujourd'hui
tout un arsenal de lois antiterroristes
qui ont été votées depuis quelques
années on a même pas fait le bilan qui
permet de joindre sa chose précédent
quinquennat lors nous permettent déjà
beaucoup de choses sans forcément qu'il
y ait un avis du juge judiciaire qui
soit posée au préalable donc faisant le
bilan de tout ça et nous savons que la
plupart en réalité des mesures qui ont
été prises l'ont été dans un cadre qui
n'est pas un cadre liés à l'état
d'urgence par contre qui a été lié à
l'état d'urgence c'est ça on nous a pas
répondu c'est la répression de
manifestations syndicales de
manifestation écologique qui jusqu'à
preuve du contraire n'ont aucun rapport
avec les terroristes donc tout ça nous
inquiète surtout qu' on ne retrouve
certains traits caractéristiques dans la
prochaine loi qui doit venir devant la
santé n'étaient par exemple comme le
fait de le fête de prod2 propre de
prévoir des cerises les zones de
protection ce qu'on a connus par la loi
comme riz où vous pourriez même être
palper par des officiers de sécurité
privée d'accord ce contrôle de police
mais privé une atteinte aux libertés l'a
donc c'est une atteinte aux libertés et
toute atteinte aux libertés sert les
ennemis de la république c'est-à-dire
les terros vais les faire est-ce que
vous avez la possibilité de saisir le
conseil constitutionnel à des
initiatives qui peuvent être envisagées
écoutez sur l'état d'urgence sur la
prolongation là non pour l'instant
puisque ça va venir jusqu'en novembre
on regrette que youssouf vote tous qu'on
voit bien le cercle le cycle infernal
dans lequel on est c'est à dire un
député dans marche nous a dit ah oui
mais que direz vous à la prochaine
victime du respect lorsque l on reste
tout le temps dans l'état d'urgence je
vous rappel c'est quand même un état
d'exception qui désirent qui lui est de
pouvoir judiciaire et policier pas
d'initiative autant pas en tout cas pour
le rendre au parc on trouvera qui à pied
sur la prochaine loi pour vérifier
malheureusement on a beaucoup de crainte
là dessus qu'elle ne soit pas une
attaque permanente aux libertés matière
au est avec nous représenter le figaro
notre partenaire c'est à vous tout de
suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vaut-il bonjour michael bonjour katia
bonjour eric coquerel on va parler un
petit peu du groupe de la france un
soumise à l'assemblée nationale votre
présidence et jean luc mélenchon mais il
est aussi une autre forte tête c'est
françois ruffin il a répété cette
semaine qu'il ne devait rien à la france
insoumise
est ce qu'il n'ya pas un risque de
guerre des ego en tout cas de
concurrence entre jean luc mélenchon et
françois ruffin oh non pas du tout j'ai
pas entendu cette phrase donc je vais
pas la commenter
non non ça se passe super bien vraiment
il ya je sais on a bien compris qu'on
allait que certains allaient essayer de
deux médecins en scène
mais vous savez il ya beaucoup de tact
forte tête dans ce groupe il ya clementi
de teint et alexis corbière il ya
hadrien cotten est-ce qu'on a vue puis
un à d'autres vous allez voir qu'ils
vont émerger au fur et à mesure bon j'en
fais partie donc moi je n'envie pas ça
du tout comme ça avec françois il est il
est pleinement intégré dans le groupe il
nous amène des mêmes des idées des
initiatives par exemple la question de
la de permettre la cravate comme symbole
c'est lui de françois et de clémentine
autain non je ne vis pas ça du tout
comme ça je vous rassure il n'y a pas de
problème aussi de discipline de de
consignes on parle beaucoup des élus la
république en marche de la superbe le
godillot vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs vous
même à l'instant est-ce qui a pas un
risque aussi de caporalisation de votre
côté mais non vous vous savez pas que
nous parlons pouvait des réunions à
chaque fois on prend des décisions
ensemble d'accords avec des discussions
des avis ont des chercheurs trouver un
consensus
jean luc et des fois d'accord avec la
décision qui est prise à la fin des fois
nous voyez ça peut décider de la
reconduction des ensembles voici
d'ensemble arrêt pas changé c'est
dangereux qui n'a heureusement que
franchement interrogé tous les députés
où vous allez et est une bien sûr que
non nous on aime bien le débat argumenté
on aime bien se convaincre
on peut des fois discute on a discuté
par an passé longtemps sur l'histoire de
versailles du boycott du congrès voilà
mon nom ne vous savez on est on est
démocratique on est des gens normaux
olivier faur qui est le président du
groupe nouvelle gauche considère que
vous êtes dans la politique spectacle
ils vous reprochent d'être dans une
opposition caricaturale au gouvernement
il
je pense qu'ils parlaient d'eux
l'épisode des à cravate mais aussi du
code du travail cette semaine dans
l'hémicycle qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez je paraisse que ses doutes
est ce qu'il est ce que c'est très
intéressant de vous cibler nous au
moment où gouvernement propose une
politique qui casse le code du travail
qui annonce des mesures d'austérité je
n'ai peut-être pas l'impression le nan
ça le regarde si pour se distinguer il
tape sur le seul groupe qui
effectivement est cohérent parce qu'on a
tous voté contre la confiance bon je
suppose que c'est une manière un peu de
camoufler les problèmes du parti
socialiste qui eux se divise entre
contre abstention et pour un parti sadi
à a lancé son mouvement la semaine
dernière il a quitté justement le parti
socialiste sauf que ça a l'air de vous
agacer je fais référence à votre tweet
ou vous l'accusez de division vous lui
demandez de vous rejoindre
est-ce que cela vous inquiète-t-il
pourrez vous concurrencer non non ça
m'inquiète pas mais j'ai pas compris
pourquoi benoît hamon bilan son
mouvement c'est son droit nous on est
moi j'ai tendance à lui dire écoute et
écoute on a un mouvement la france a
soumis ce qui n'est pas un parti qui
vise à recomposer donc pour épier très
intéressé mais non seulement il vient
pas mais ils trouvent ils trouvé
intelligent nous nous attaquer sur la
question de la cravate et autres je vois
pas l'intérêt est franchement dans la
période je vois pas l'intérêt de
commencer à affaiblir ou être vouloir
diviser ceux qui s'opposent à emmanuel
macron c'était ça ma réaction
sympathique julie rejoins nous c'est pas
c'est pas quelque chose de désagréable
une dernière question la dernière
question en tout dernier mot sur nicolas
hulot qui a annoncé hier son plan climat
il a détaillé ces mesures
est-ce que vous jugez ses premiers pas
au gouvernement réussisse obsédé on aime
bien nicolas hulot france a soumis
serait il à voter pour jean luc
mélenchon il a dit bon on n'a pas tout à
fait la même conception des choses il
pense qu'il peut il peut permettre
d'avancer dans un contexte qui est
mauvais pour autant moi ce que je
regarde c'est qu'il ya quelques bonnes
mesures sur par exemple l'isolation
thermique la question la taxe carbone
mais ça ne prend pas suffisamment en
compte la globalité du projet il ya rien
prendre soin
pourquoi en tout cas ne comme il est à
la tête d'un gouvernement qui applique
une politique productiviste libérale de
libre échange
il va se retrouver vite coincé mais
quand vous sur les accords de libre
échange et c'est sur les perturbateurs
endocriniens
ça vous fait d'être enchaîné notamment
cette semaine
oui oui enfin ouais je n'ai pas bien vu
le nom c'est pas grave on répondre sais
pas j'ai pas regardé losc ça vous semble
cohérent normalement je pense qu'il ya
je pense qu'on ne peut pas faire une
politique tel que lui l'a souhaité nous
savons qu'il est sincère dans ses
objectifs
à l'intérieur du de d'un gouvernement
qui ne remet pas en question nucléaire
qui ne remet pas en question le tout
camion qui ne remet pas en question les
accords de libre échange qui par exemple
ne parle plus de taxes de transactions
financières au niveau européen voilà
tout ça il nous manque que j'allais dire
le la cohérence
bon maintenant s'il arrive à faire
passer quelques mesures temps même si le
trait qu un dernier mot sur les
communistes on vous sait assez divisés
vous êtes vous siégez de façon séparée à
la 110e minute faire comment ça comment
ça se passe quand on leur a proposé de
faire un groupe commun pour un
quinquennat
on verra bien comment ça évolue mais ils
ont pas voulu du coup ils ont fait un
groupe un petit peu patchwork je dis ça
sans avec quelques députés le tram 1 qui
ont qui ont qui se sont abstenus sur la
confiance dans ce convoi nous on pense
qu'on aurait été plus cohérent
maintenant ils ont fait un groupe
leonidas l'économiste apporte au verbe t
oui sisiphe un il ya quelques députés on
sait qu'ils souhaiteraient comme les à
fouzilhon marie george buffet stéphane
peu qu'ils souhaiteraient plutôt et de
fer ou comme avec toi on verra bien
comment ça évolue avec mercy matière
merci on va terminer à l'image avec
l'image de celle qui aura marqué la
france par son engagement ses valeurs
simone veil hommage national rendu aux
invalides en présence du président de la
république qui a annoncé qu'elle
entrerait au panthéon avec son époux une
question eric coquerel qui a été simone
veil pour vous qu'est-ce que vous
retiendrez comment il ya deux moments
force10 amie simone veil il ya
évidemment la loi veil qui tu ne sais
pas tellement courant qu'une loi fasse
l'unanimité
c'est une des grandes voix du 20ème
siècle et qui en plus ça est porté par
une grande personnalité et puisse tout
quand on considère régionales j'étais au
camp d'auschwitz et je ne sais pas quand
vous dire que c'est la môme enfin c'est
un moment terrible quand vous allez et
j'ai pensé à elle
voilà c'est à dire c'est manifestement
de l essai sur ces dynamiques de vie
malgré tout coûte que coûte d'énergie
dans ce camp et c'était un message
d'espoir je pense qu'elle a porté toute
cette immersion termine sur ces mots
merci beaucoup eric coquerel
[Musique]
oh
son
[Musique]